juni ist weiterhin und verriet ich würde
gerne von der wissen warum sind so viele
deutschen rapper so stolz drauf um zu
sagen welchen anderen durch webber sie
hören ich meine haben sie angst dass sie
so uncool wegen oder warum und meine
andere frage wäre welchen deutschen
rapper hörst du noch gerne wäre cool
wenn ich mir die frage antwort ist ja
ich glaube nicht also ich glaube nicht
dass die also zum teil am lipper
bestimmt dann soll er doch klar die
haben einfach angst aus dem grunde
dass die herrschaften dass die wenn die
jetzt sagen ich höre den wenn jetzt so
sagt ich fahre gerne oder irgendjemand
anders dass er ihnen ihre position
wegnimmt dass die einfach angst haben
für ihre existenz oder für ihre
daseinsberechtigung und
was ich gerne höre hengst höre ich gerne
bass sultan hengzt ist ein cooler rapper
den mag ich gerne und dessen cooler typ
und er macht auch sehr gute musik